human rights we're also talking about
people not having access to abortion
clinics where they're doing the things
itself and they die right we're also
talking about women in the hospital who
are pregnant who have chosen to stay
with their pregnancy and have issues at
hospitals and hospitals that are like oh
no we don't do that listen
for whatever reason you don't need to
explain it to anybody but a lot of times
when we're talking about access to
reproductive health for me I'm thinking
about black indigenous people of color
particularly women and girls who are
working class who do not have even
access to like proper sexual education
it's the oppressive state of saying I
will force you to have a child even
against your own will right especially
when you're thinking about women and
girls who would be forced to have these
children who are already living in very
traumatized and scared and scarce
situations you want to ask about
barriers that's a barrier right there